hello and welcome to this video playing
naturist 2000 yeah hmm my big Kings
onion and something oh it ain't I been
only anti-guerrilla I'm sorry yeah i was
thinking it could easily become a
Maloney is this an interesting move i
recently saw this plate in a game that i
witnessed the idea is a 5d 594 let's see
vickers d5 hmm yeah yeah probably yeah
where am I going actually um ok cannot
go to e5 be eight it looks meek night
before hmm might be four looks decidedly
strange but going back what so is this
weird and so let's see give you a couple
of Tempe here what to do now
do you know how to not play d 6 yeah
their own name point of the set up might
be that I can attack the center with c6
andy sixx i'm just experimenting a
little bit and see what happens but this
is interesting i have this kind of thing
attacking the center ok maybe he can
take only 60 just take only six nope
yeah this is not so threatening I would
assume anyway what to do here I think is
good before lined up and I want to make
sure that doesn't happen
hmm okay
yeah I don't really think this is a good
position but we'll see what happens I
tried Queenie seven roop the eight maybe
and I probably need some cover for this
pawn it's got 9 p-5 also the other night
on a six hmm that's not a great piece
the only thing is I would love to play
is going for the pin here Queen f8 wear
this uniform
hmm ok so you see going for f4 maybe I'm
just in time on 66 cm huh doesn't look
good him ok so what's the point I don't
know 5e fibers a threat definitely a
threat 96 hmm yeah that's what she
gather for experimenting not great to
put it very very mildly him so I think
maybe I'm still ok but I wouldn't be
surprised if my position is falling
apart him p tried to play age 6 get rid
of that that pin queen fo is still
interesting move just attacking the sir
f6 night yeah the other kid this is also
interesting yeah I thought him with an
attack 1c form and this is something he
has to attend to in some way okay this
is a page six
yeah g5g five is not a move I like to
play hmm ok this is not so bad I guess
okay heading for deform maybe it's just
grabbing it nope no he isn't
okay okay maybe now this I don't think
that now mighty form and takes takes
Queen takes that's night takes you for
tough tough position maybe you can take
on d4 and then take on the six for some
folks might be okay wow really I was
thinking that this must be great while
at least at least good bye not why isn't
that good for black I'll just take 2 3
next and then play d5 that should be
excellent now now now it's good my two
bishops now come to life III is also and
also week and I'll just take this pawn
you should only force not doing much my
ideas queen to d6 rook to detune this is
simple and strong ok so maybe hyh form
try to be aggressive here don't see many
active possibilities for white and
disposition going to be five maybe maybe
this is a move taking my bishop and um
nope time were caged for I cannot play
sure how to do this just to prove the
position slightly have h4 maybe in the
future
okay why can I not take it don't see it
white resins jam a very tough position
and I don't think I've had a good
position yeah I don't know this is a as
mentioned recently a friend of mine got
yeah somewhat played this against him
and he responded um Bishop e3 and after
he 5 d 594 this was quite interesting
for black and then one just wonder why
didn't he do this this is just good
right why do I black cannot go here this
is just losing the house so black has to
kind of stumble around here with an item
and here this must be must be something
okay so i take the send and he I
expected him to take on e6 I mean you
know where this is a playable position
for black he is certainly a bit worse
but um yeah since nothing particularly
bad i didn't like d takes his 64 white
what he played but it didn't turn out to
be so badly here white is definitely
better yeah all this feels normal and
white has an advantage a he's got that
very annoying pin pressure on the d file
and jim-jim yeah here i was also
thinking that before might be an option
it was one of the few reasons why the
night is doing something on a six
controlling be form like this maybe okay
i can take and go here
it's always the problem I try to go age
six and hear from here on like it's kind
of ok i think the engine is still giving
white an edge but how bad is it really i
don't think that's so bad ok give 0.2 or
0.3 right here the engine wants to do
this stockfish
hmm edit it it looks okay for white of
course but there is no clean way forward
you cannot go if I've and I have ideas
like this and this it is still not
particularly great I came this and now I
had this idea to jump in to deform the
real the real question is here when I
played 94 I thought he might be able to
take on d6 and plate you five mmm yeah
this is possible this was there this was
the thing with 95 why I wasn't sure
about it this is pleased as possible you
know that was possible and I'm down the
exchange it is not a super clear
position actually because I have pretty
good player with this knight on d4
possible dark square play this is not
just an exchange down I have some
compensation that knight on d4 computer
is giving this is always or almost equal
well that wasn't intended so that Ross
would have been a lucky lucky thing that
again this doesn't work at all I have 95
black is clear deep ellum now here the
position is more or less winning for
black it just falls apart and he cannot
cannot keep this position together I
might not have played the best possible
wave and I kept a big advantage I think
yeah this was just giving the piece but
it's very difficult to give white any
advice the engine wants to play Queen to
e5 and rope here yeah it's just a huge
pressure there's age for coming G for
coming and yeah it just isn't it is just
isn't good and it is on minus five
pounds or so this is rather rather huge
it also gives this idea all ready to
take on g3 and we know on the dark
squares yeah I thought about this
earlier but
it didn't convince me so much okay well
thanks for watching